you know those stories that you should
just never tell your parents this is one
of them
and again they both watch my youtube
channel so so you guys are gonna find
out this way
long story short a Michael Bay action
scene just [ __ ] on my day the other day
and keep in mind this story is
absolutely real this happened I was
driving to work on the freeway the other
day going freeway speed 60 miles an hour
or 90 6.5 km/h for you metric folk some
douchebags exits coming up and he's
about three lanes away from it and I am
driving right between him and his
precious exit both of us going 60 miles
an hour can you see where this is going
he crosses two of the lanes he's about
to get into mine which means he's going
to hit me there's no doubt about that I
look to the left and I see emerging
full-speed into me so I just go and I
turn my wheel to the right and my car
spins out going 60 this is where [ __ ]
gets real my car spins out I'm now
sliding backwards on the freeway a cars
gonna hit me I turned the wheel to the
left to try to even it out it goes right
past me just misses me and my car spins
out to the left into the freeway where
everyone else is going 60 miles an hour
my car is spinning out of control the
guys about the t-boned me he just misses
me the car still spinning I just miss
another accident a cars about to smack
me head-on I just miss him and my car
comes to a stop now facing opposite
traffic and I just see a fleet of
vehicles all coming right at me going 60
miles an hour
and who is the front-runner leading the
pack Optimus Prime a semi that is
literally going to hit me head-on you
know how they say your life flashes
before your eyes that already happened
as I was spinning out of control
entering the traffic at this point I
just had one thought left I'm gonna die
before the new Mortal Kombat comes out
seriously dude this is [ __ ] I'm not
gonna lie a head-on collision in the
freeway due to some douchebag trying to
drive through me to make his exit not
really the way I want to go out the semi
driver sees me and just blew smoke just
start screaming from his tires as he
slams on his brakes he tries to swerve
right the rest of the semi body it does
not it starts to turn this way like it's
gonna jackknife and just smack my car
this blows the truck swerves to the
right and I swear to god the semi body
evens out and just misses my car by an
inch when he's done the rest of the
vehicular Armada coming at me on the
freeway see my car and they all just
scream on their brakes and they all
actually stop before they hit me in
which I just sat there for a second not
gonna lie I was kind of frozen and then
I turned around and continued to work me
my car and every other vehicle on the
road got through that
question without a scratch thanks God no
problem Jeremy all right apparently God
is skinny and pale too and wears Hef's
robe that's cool so the lesson here is
drive safe and if some douchebags gonna
cross two lanes across the freeway and
hit you try honking at him whatever you
do just don't sharply turn your wheel
going 60 not gonna lie I think I lucked
out on this one do all you drivers out
there who don't check your blind spot
when you're merging we'll check that
[ __ ] because that's how this kind of
[ __ ] happens adrenaline rushes awesome
freeway wipeouts not good so does anyone
else out there have one of those oh [ __ ]
I'm gonna die kind of moments comment
video respond let me know it'll be
therapeutic you got to get that [ __ ] out
but the lesson in all this the
underlying story is if death comes for
you just punch him in the face
[Music]